we are live episode number 51 with tom
ellsworth biz doc
and adam sausage question for you what
do you think about 51 the number 51 what
do you think about
everything to me in my mind number has
to do with something what does 51 tell
you
when you think about the number 51 give
me a jersey give me a year
give me whatever something to do with
51. really throwing me off here pat i
got nothing
something with 51. uh it's it's it's
basically how elections are won in the
united states now
okay that's how you think about it 51.
just a smidgen so 49 people up 48
this is a crazy stat i'm about to give
you okay see
cecil fielder's best year in home runs
was 51.
okay for what it's worth i know it's
worth nothing but that's the weird stats
part ridiculously i may be off if
somebody verifies it right now
you're wrong i think it was 51. last
night we had a little uh controversy at
dinner debate we didn't we forgot the
exact amount of dimaggios
56. you said 51.
adrian said 52 mario who knows all the
facts with sports
but it's 50 seconds
but we had a good time last night uh
mayor uh mayor francis juarez from miami
and the guy's a uh quality guy he's got
a lot of presents a ton of swagger
okay event was with your best friend
adrian yes um
whom adrian has been all over the world
we learned he lived in cnbc
jerusalem for three years and he was all
over the place they said party you know
thursday night
tel aviv i think it was uh saturdays tel
aviv thursday night is
jerusalem we had a lot of good stories
that guy is uh it was a meeting
yesterday for nfts and crypto
i mean the whole meeting yesterday at
soho house and miami was about crypto
and nft
it's interesting to see bringing capital
to miami and
miami being the capital of capital
attracting all the
you know and today i don't know if you
guys saw the taxes today with cuomo he
announced it this morning
where they were talking not he announced
this morning what they were talking
about this morning
raising taxes in new york that's going
to end up costing 4.3 billion dollars
it's already been announced top earners
uh all across the board taxes to
generate 4.3 billion dollars
after losing all the jobs that they've
lost
they are still raising taxes you know
what i like about what marijuana said
yesterday
suarez suarez said yesterday here's what
i like about what he said yesterday
by the way the guy could have been a
model on cover of a gq magazine he's got
that kind of a look
and he's got everything he's got
everything yeah
he's conservative but he kind of runs
from the middle he said he said uh uh
well he's a democrat apparently
you know he's he's a miami republican
meaning he's socially liberal for sure
you live in miami
but a fiscal responsibility i like that
that's it every chance
i get to lower taxes i do every chance
to low regulation i do and every chance
to bring more talent to miami
i do that's my priority says i want to
make sure everybody knows miami it's one
of the best cities we have in america he
believes it's the best city the best
city in america
but it is what he saw the shot that he
took in new york yeah he was pretty
vocal about that he goes look
i don't know what the hell they're doing
there but they're definitely going in
the wrong direction
moved to miami yeah he was not
hesitating at all no he was not
hesitating at all and tom
i know one thing about you tom used to
party hardcore in miami years ago wow
tell us about your partying days in
miami
um what part you want to tell me go as
possible no no i was not a partier in
miami we were
shocking no no we were middle class
people would come down
spring break and stuff like that and and
do things but i was
never a big party or i had never had the
dollars to go to the big clubs
or even back then the big clubs you know
well that makes two of us tom i've never
partied down in miami
so one thing about you extremely
conservative yeah two girls in his life
mom and a girlfriend that's it that's
right that's a that's a very committed
thing by the way your story last night
about minute ball
oh you're like was fantastic yeah about
how you met manuel you're at a bar
fantastic one-on-one at a bar yes got
that guy drunk
maybe at the end of the podcast the last
five minutes you'll tell them
i'll tell the story but let's let's get
into some of the stories that we have
today
we got a lot of crazy stories to go
through today charles barkley
was asked during a college basketball
game his thoughts on what's going on
with politics and his reaction we're
gonna show the video
in a minute here i loved what he had to
say about it and then
linkedin apparently has given their
entire employees 15 000 employees the
week off
literally all of them the week off we'll
cover that here in a minute
delta cancels over 100 flights dana
white to sell his remaining stake
in ufc two decades after buying it for
only a couple million dollars
and turning it into a seven or an eight
billion dollar company and now he's
selling the rest of his shares
here's what two-thirds of americans have
to say uh what uh did with their
stimulus checks interesting where they
use their money
all those phone numbers 533 million
facebook uh phone numbers and personal
data
leaked online including the founders
zuckerberg's phone number
ceos reflect on their pandemic here in
the lessons they've learned amazon is on
the age of
alabama union vote which is going crazy
bernie sanders all over that yesterday
investors should buy real assets from
wine to art
as inflation reaches a secular turning
point
bank of america says think about a bank
of america is suggesting you buy
real assets from wine to art bank of
america when would you have thought that
bank of america would have said
to buy wine to art nft
price crash steers debate on weather
stimulus
led fat is over with like 74 percent
christ some big number there
godzilla versus kong tops the pandemic
box i watch it twice by the way in less
than 24. i got a lot of questions i
watch it one night
hbo the next i promised mario was going
to go with them so
myself and the kids watched it twice
within 20 it was like a homework
assignment we had
phenomenal movie fun and i'm not i got
questions yes we'll cover that as well
goldman sachs google and amazon prepare
for return to office microsoft wins u.s
army contract
for augmented reality headset worth 21.9
billion
over the next 10 years trump changes the
way he brands himself from trump
to the 45th is that a good idea or bad
idea
yelling to push this is something i
definitely want to talk about today
yelling to push for global
minimum tax on corporation mlb moving
all-star game
out of atlanta in response to the
georgia voting law which by the way for
some of you that don't know
what's really in it i printed out a
couple things to read one is from
washington post
one is from heritage action to talk
about what's in the actual
law that they're pitching to see is it
as bad as the media
telling new laws in georgia the new long
georgia that's got folks to move the
all-star game uh florida governor
desantis
signs executive order banning vaccine
passports in the state of florida
u.s and iran agreed to resume talks over
nuclear nuclear deal
france to close schools putin
voted sexiest man in russia
putin voted secretary
[Laughter]
uh dmx rapper uh not in good shape it's
very unfortunate he had won the greatest
uh albums of all time yep and
unopened super mario brothers game sells
from 1986
for 660 000 and tom brady's rookie card
sells for record-breaking 2.25
so hamming said that with all those
stories yeah do you want to just get
right into
the story you wanted to talk about what
you which is uh
how folks in america are spending their
stimulus checks
that's going to be awesome before we do
can i give a quick shout out sure
because people are asking kai's not with
us today yes
kai is a little hungover we went out
friday night he had one too many orange
juices
and he's nodded with us today tell the
truth though tell the truth
he had about four or five sam and kai
got into a fight
sam told him i'm gonna run it today
because he's trying to impress a girl
cause he's on the camera look at it he's
shaving look how
perfectly shaved look at that baby face
sam is colombian he's single he lives in
boca ladies if you're interested dm
sam carvajal carvajal sam's usually
behind the scenes running the show now
he's filling in for kai
it is what it is they may or may not be
roommates they're friends they don't
like the comments about his hair by the
way that upset him a little bit
because he's going for the bear he got
hope you feel better get well soon yes
okay
so let's talk about stimulus checks
here's how two-thirds of americans have
used their stimulus checks those 1400
stimulus checks that started hitting
mailboxes in march are proven valuable
to people overwhelmed by debt
a study from bill paying service daxo
finds that 62 percent of stimulus checks
are being used to pay bills
with a significant portion of the
earmark for crediting uh
credit card debt since the start of the
pandemic says doc so 42
americans have skipped paying at least
one bill interesting
42 percent of americans have skipped
paying one bill the doxor number fall in
line with the data from u.s census
bureau household pulse
survey in march a study from that group
show the majority of stimulus checks
recipients planned
to use the money on food and utilities
as household budgets
remain stretched during the pandemic a
study of 110 million people who reported
receiving stimulus checks taken between
february 14
february 17 and march 4 showed debt
reduction
and household expenses as the top
priorities
adam thoughts yeah i mean this is
there's a lot to unpack here i actually
love this story so
um i think the number is 90 of americans
are receiving some form of stimulus
i didn't get a check though unit well if
you make over 75 000 which i assume you
do pat i know you've had some up and
down years but
uh if you make under seventy five
thousand dollars or less you'll get
fourteen hundred dollars i get phases
out i believe it eighty thousand dollars
like if you make
seventy eight thousand as an example you
might get a check for like 800 bucks
but then it starts to phase out if
you're married you get a you make
if you have a household income if you're
married if you're under 150
000 you'll get uh the full 2800 and if
you have dependents that are each
getting so
you know i went down to south beach and
i was interviewing a lot of people down
there what they did
phenomenal by the way thank you check it
out on valuetainment economics a great
amazing interview one girl
she i said oh how much you get 1400 she
goes no 4 200 i go wow that's amazing
you're married kids dependents all that
i go how much did you spend to be here
4 200 oh my god what are you doing
what are you doing so there's a lot of
those kind of interviews down there in
south beach but
here's why i love this story so much
two-thirds of americans
have used their stimulus check to pay
off debt so
you know i have my six principles of
wealth philosophy
and number one is having a game plan for
your money which is a budget what's your
income what your expenses and all that
and then i say number two is before you
can win the money game
don't lose and what's losing losing is
debt
so debt is your money going backwards so
the average
interest rate on a credit card is
sixteen percent in america
the average how the average credit card
amount
in debt is six thousand dollars so if
you're getting 1400
check or even a forty two hundred dollar
dollar check the best return on your
investment
might be to pay down that 16 interest
rate or in some cases 24 25
interest rate or if you have a payday
loan it might be four or 500 percent
get the f out of debt before you can
start saving and start investing i know
there's other stories out there that
tama i'll hand it over to you
people that don't have debt are actually
pumping their money right into the stock
market into robinhood
and becoming investors so here's my last
point 80
of americans have debt 80 of americans
have some form of debt
only 55 percent of americans are
actually investing in the stock market
so your goal should be to have a game
plan for your money get that f
out of debt start to save that money so
you can start investing
so i applaud these people that actually
paid off their debt with that
good for them good for them tom what do
you think well i think americans are
behaving responsibly and i think it's
great uh you
basically got them paying for they're
saying hey we're spending this on core
living
you know household expenses and food
core living and i'm also knocking down
some debt that i had i think that's a
very responsible thing to do
now does that bring back main street
does that make bring back restaurants
and
entertainment in in towns and cities no
not yet
but i think for the average american for
inside the household i think it's very
good but is it bringing back
you know the life to the cities and um
never mind spring break
never mind what's going on you know
south texas or south florida
what i'm talking about is casual
entertainment in any town usa
you know going out to do something going
out to dinner restaurants are just now
open
so that's not getting a lot of support
but i think it's really good news that
americans are doing this
because i think it makes it you know you
don't want all the americans stressed
and i think this is a very good thing
flip side you know the single americans
you met one i don't think that was the
terribly responsible answer she gave
but also you had millennials that were
single saying hey thanks for the
stimulus i'm going to go buy some crypto
and i have my coinbase account and i'm
gonna go
buy some nfts you know some interesting
things some music clips that i like
i'm like uh that's you know that's a
great story for
national media because it's like the oh
my gosh kind of
angle to the head wait so you're saying
not a good idea to take your stimulus to
go buy nfts
no i don't think so if somebody said hey
i put it in my
you know i maxed out my annual limit
from my 401k and bought a
you know some more stock in some mutual
or something okay great
that's that's a savings plan but when
you hear like the
hey i'm just going to gamble with it if
i lose it or lose so what do you think
about nfts
what do you think about nft i think look
i think this is a new collectible that's
here to stay
but i'm saying that those millennials
that took the stimulus check and the
first thing
they did was basically gamble you know
higher risk i don't think that's too
smart but i love what american families
and households did with the stimulus
people trying to get rich quick is what
you're saying well so what did you do
with your stimulus check
what's the stimulus you're so funny
speaking of nfts i know we were at the
event last night with the mayor
and adrian and the ethernet and
everything they're doing and and uh
big cloud everything that's going on
with that but you actually did an
awesome motivation monday this past week
about doing some research and
what was the motivation for that because
if you i mean i i i'll
sort of paraphrase you kind of yeah i'll
give you an idea last night i get a call
from george palau while we're at dinner
at soho house he texts me says pat
should i buy this card or not
and he sends me this beautiful giannis
you know
rookie card you know bgs name ponco
you know he sends me almost he say you
say it see if you can say it
giannis anton
so that's why i just said janice he sent
me this message he says he says uh
should i buy this card or should i not
buy this card it's a bgs nine and a half
and a bgs
uh it's a bgs 10 cart and antenna auto
right is what he sent me tom and he says
do you think this is a good price to
send
to buy and i said here's the numbers i
sent him a few things for him to look at
and even yesterday you know i got i got
a bunch of new cars that came in i got a
1958 atlantic frank sinatra card psa 10.
okay this is amazing i got to know that
they have these kind of sofia loren
autograph i'm a big sophomore you know
by the way look at this one here this is
the highest graded grace
kelly meghan's megan merkel's hero
grace kelly psa 9 highest graded
psa 9. this is a special card right
there i got a clark gable 1957 card psa
9.
i got this one tom will appreciate
another grace kelly lawrence olivier i
got a malcolm x card psa 10.
uh i got a marlon brando card from uh
1950. look at this stud right here man
marlon brando 1915 wow this before he
was dating james dean
elizabeth taylor tom you're gonna uh uh
adam i think you'll like this
this is another uh uh sophia lorraine
card autograph she was ridiculous
elvis presley psa9 she was the original
you know anyway kind of a round woman
you know round woman no you're
a bustier lady well before it was
marilyn monroe it was sofia loren
and kim kardashian all of these guys are
part of the lineage of sofioloran
okay this is before she was before
marilyn monroe sophia
i don't know if it's before melania i
think it's about an era after but
marilyn monroe anyway so interject real
quick yeah i mean you had the marilyn
monroe
like these are gorgeous you know
full-figured women now you're
these types of people you're just a
standard instagram model that's all you
today
i think sophia loren today would have a
few hundred million followers oh clearly
i mean she's if sophie's top of the top
of the list twenty-five people now any
girl that takes a picture like that
you're just a standard instagram
so so you're not that i'm hating here's
where i'm going did you ask the question
you said yes
what do you say about research right so
there's
the the one thing with tom give you a
perfect example with tom i've spent a
lot of time with tom
tom and i have traveled i don't know how
many places we've gone to
together i tell you one thing about tom
okay if you watch his case studies the
guys
like yesterday's ducati case study that
just came out today sick we watch it on
the drive to miami right sick
you learn so much about it right one of
tom's biggest strengths i learned from
him okay
just watching him not even like asking
him tom's a
master researcher okay he researches
so is greg share so is the most
successful people i've done business
with
there is this ability to research that
people don't put value behind
so even today with nfts yesterday when i
was calling we were on the phone with
jake yesterday on the way to miami
and i'm talking about bit cloud because
i'm getting ready to you know introduce
it to a few different people and
we're talking to crypto attorneys can
they be sued how can you be sued are you
selling securities what could happen
what could not happen you got to do
research to get your questions
yeah so so these these things with cards
these things with nfts we're being hit
up by so many different angles
right now so many different things are
being talked about right now that we
don't know about
so rather than just jumping in and
saying i'm going to go in there and i
mean i don't know what's going on
i'm going to do it why don't you take a
full day and research two of the topics
that interest you the most exactly
that's all i'm talking about you know
that's what you got to be doing you got
to do your own case studies
but you talked about you know nfts with
millennials putting their money in nfts
i'm going to go into the stats about
nfts okay
which has to do with what happened with
stimulus check stop and so
nft price crash steers debate on whether
stimulus led
fat is over this is a bloomberg story
how it started in february 20
000 buyers spent more than 45 million
dollars
on basketball clips in a single day let
me say that one more time 20
000 buyers spent 45 million dollars on
basketball clips in a single day today
the average price of nft is essentially
trading
tradable digital certificates that use
blockchain technologies to prove
ownership and pro
providence on online assets have tumbled
almost
70 percent from a peak in february to
about 1400
chris wilmer university of pittsburgh
academic who co-edited to blockchain
research journal said nfts aren't in a
bubble any more than cryptocurrencies is
a bubble
there will be manias and irrational
exuberance but cryptocurrencies cleared
here to stay
with us for the long term and nf these
are probably two nfts are far
from risk-free whether due to further
further price drops
so-called wash training trading where
deals that look
uh genuine are actually done by small
group to create an illusion of high
demand
or plain fraud i'm going to read that
last part one more time folks if you're
listening
let me read that last part again and i
want to give your thoughts on this
nfd's are far from risk-free whether due
to further price
drops so-called wash trading wash
trading it's a wash you buy from a
friend at a high price
and you kind of make it work but the
price of the nft goes higher
where deals that look genuine are
actually done by small groups to create
an illusion of high demand
or plain fraud that is happening that's
not everybody that's happening with a
small percentage that's given a bad rep
tom
thoughts on nfts well you know what
easter was yesterday and there is
no new sin in the world that's what we
found out the sinfulness and the greed
of man
is consistent and what you see here on
nfts there's a little phrase called pump
and dump
and that's written down right here yep
that's exactly right this has been going
on
since the pink sheets hey i've got the
pink sheets by the way which were
ultra low jordan belford yeah the ultra
low special correct ultra low price
stocks are out there
a bunch of guys get together create some
trades there's a little pop looks like
momentum they
they get on the phone uh start calling
people
fake research reports pump and dump pop
pop
boom oh my gosh you're right i just
looked at that thing you're right it was
at two yesterday and that's two and a
half now it's three three and a quarter
four
oh my goodness at four dollars a share i
could get in there with wow a hundred
dollars i get 25
wow i could put the thousand dollars i
could get this pumping up tomorrow
morning it's back up 1.75
and so it's nothing new it's nothing
going on it's going to continue going on
an unregulated product today and for
people that
you know millennials or someone maybe
younger younger entrepreneurs listening
pumping up with something that was
happening in the 70s and 80s and kind of
that kind of went away but in wolf of
wall street you saw the the the the
i'm going to give a compliment different
side of what you're saying right so what
i'm saying is
this is nothing new and so people say
wow where did this come from
this crime is not a new idea i'm going
to give you a completely different side
yeah did you want to say something on
that
i kind of know where you're going but
i'm gonna i think i think the fact that
it is
non-fungible this key word for you know
where i'm going
yeah so i don't i mean i'm setting you
up for dude why don't you just tell us
your gift of reading people's minds oh
yeah i haven't i understand give
well i'll tell you why tell me because
i'm going to bring this back to you now
baby
say it because i loved your intro from
that video you did yesterday and you
said look you know
you you everyone you've seen pat you're
a researcher as well i'm becoming more
of a researcher
you know the osmosis with the biz doc
but you said i don't
i don't i say i don't know what uh what
crypto is i'm not um
i don't understand what big uh
blockchain is what's an nft what's
fungible i don't know what fungible
means
i don't and then you said listen a lot
of people don't know it's okay
do your research and i had to do dude
and i got
a year ago if you asked me what an nft
was i was like what did you just spell
nfl wrong
i have no clue what it was a year ago
most people don't even know what
fungible was two weeks ago okay there we
go today
yeah but you are a good mind reader you
have espn
an nfl reference espn we're going sports
here not too much sportszone
valuetainers
um but that's where i'm thinking that
you know your story that you always tell
about the picasso
but the freaking picasso yeah but the
guy goes to the death bed and sees
picasso in his last painting
the beauty of these non-fungibles is you
can't
duplicate them you can't sort of bring
the pump and dump corruption mentality
to this so i'm setting you up because
i'm sure you have more to elaborate on
i'm going a completely different
direction okay so i'm going a completely
different direction so the story starts
off with us talking about stimulus
checks right yes sir
what these kids did and then tom talked
about them being responsible and you
talk about the
one girl you met in miami that spent
what 4 200.
i'm assuming that's 1400 times three
which is forty four dollars
great she blew it so that's what she did
right here's here's where i go
go to the 18 year old tom go to the 18
year old when i was partying in spring
break
when he was a miami non-stop go to the
18 year old pbd right right my chain and
my clock yeah i can see that chain
hundred clock you're a flavor flavor
but if you go back to the 20 20 year old
18 euro pbd i'm in the army i'm getting
out of the army
i have no clue what to do okay let me
tell you what i did with my money let me
tell you what i did with my money
uh i did anything i could to 10x my
money okay
i bought penny stocks i bought a penny
stock one time for five cents
this penny stock within a week went to
75 cents
i was on top of the world for one hour
and then it went back to three cents and
i thought you know i should have got out
i didn't get out though i didn't get up
because with penny stocks you can't sell
as fast as you can with you know
different kind of stocks a different
kind of thing
so then i said you know what screw this
i took my money and i just went and
bought a bunch of nike stock i started
fooling around online and then i went
and bought
a bunch of different things i started
risking my money in these different
things
you know how much i ended up losing i
lost 49 thousand dollars i was on forty
nine thousand dollars of debt in my
early twenties
debt in my early twenties why taking a
crap
load of risk nonsense risk that had no
clue
what i was doing with my money an
informed risk uninformed risk
then finally non-research risks
21 22 i get my series seven okay i go to
morgan stanley you get my 63 all those
licenses that comes to me
then i started learning about the
ability to research then i start
focusing on one industry things change
here's my point
if you're young and you're listening to
this
you're 18 19 20 21 and you're screwing
off with your money you're throwing into
nfts or whatever you're doing
there's a part of me that says that 18
year old tom may have done that a little
bit
there's a part of me that says the 18
year old adam may have been like you
know what i don't know there's a part of
me that says
because you know as you get older all
you want to do is you want to talk about
how responsible we were and we forget
about how irresponsible
we were and there's an element of taking
that risk that the younger generation is
doing
if you're going to spend 4 200 at a
nightclub versus putting it in nft's
guess what i'm banking for
yeah go into the nfts you know go into
the nfts and see see what that can turn
into
but if there is any advice you can take
from three men sitting at this table in
their 40s i'm gonna leave it at that
three gentlemen sitting at this table in
their 40s 40s means you're about 40. so
we're all in our 40s
is do some research on any
of these topics let's go into what the
bank of america
folks are saying speaking of research
investors should buy real assets from
wine to art as
inflation reaches a secular turning
point bank of america says
a story by business insider since the
election
president joe biden inflation and its
potential come back
has been a hot economic topic pumping
trillions of dollars into the economy
could overheat critics say while others
see few signs of runway inflation either
now or near future bank of america chief
investment strategist
michael hartnett has seen enough to
declare
a secular turning point on inflation and
anticipates that stock market
returns will be lackluster over the next
decade let me read that one more time
this is not an employee at bank of
america this is not a director
this is not an advisor this is not an
accountant this is the chief
investment strategist michael hartnett
has seen enough to declare a secular
turning point on inflation anticipates
that stock market returns will be
lackluster over the next decade stock
investors who've seen
a roughly 10 annual return from recent
decades
should expect that gain to go down to
three to five percent over the course of
20 20s he added
but he has a recommendation buy real
assets such as real estate commodities
and even collectibles like wine art
diamonds
cars could outperform in the next decade
you know what this is this is
collectibles
these are things that you cannot
duplicate you cannot get another grace
kelly psa 10 1955 card
you can't duplicate these things right
the chance of that happening is slim to
none
so investors don't need to own the
physical assets hartnett added but
instead can own
reits real estate investment trusts and
specialized funds that focus
on these assets so he's p he's saying
the next decade if you read it right
land is going to go up real estate is
going to go up anything that you can
just
print is going to go up tom i'm going to
go to uh first on this story what are
your thoughts
you agree with them okay b of a is alter
ego in the investment banking world and
wall street is
goldman merrill lynch merrill lynch yeah
yep so
that's right they bought them out like
in 11 years ago or 10 years ago
and it just so happens we have a reit
and a specialized fund that we could
help you out with this
so there's a little bit of there's a
little bit of retail sale here going on
but i
i think he's right because he's he's
describing
a simple analysis if inflation goes up
and these returns go to three to five
over here then your return could be
you know ten percent over here i think
that's a really
sliver of a of a gap there but you know
i i don't disagree with it
and i think with inflation i think you
know
the collectibles that are not in
infinite supply
i think that works i you know it's an
i think it's a valid investment strategy
but it's one of many strategies
yeah i think um i'll take this with a
grain of salt this is one guy there's
gonna be other analysts that are gonna
say put your money in the stock market
are you crazy this is
so i think the a couple key lessons for
all our friends out there watching this
is
number one diversification so should you
be in the stock market
a resounding yes should you have all
your money in the stock market maybe not
maybe you should diversify
and have some reads like for instance
i'm very big i rent i think i've been
very vocal about that i don't buy
houses i just kind of keep it moving and
i'm very flexible and i move from miami
to boca to dallas but it's a lifestyle
choice it's a lifestyle choice obviously
when i have kids and i settle different
story it's a different story but i might
even still rent at that point
sure but i'm all in on the stock market
and i've things have done very well over
the last decade
and change um but should you put
you know a sliver of your money in reits
maybe 10 sure should you put a ten
percent of your
five to ten percent of your assets into
crypto sure but the bulk of it should be
in the stock market in my opinion
whether it's a 40k
401k but it should be in the stock i
think so yes
i think so yes because again building
average investors yes or even
the i mean for everyone but
like don't forget building wealth is a
marathon not a sprint we talked about
the 18 year old getting into debt yes
trying to get rich quick and then i
think it worked out pretty well for you
um but it's a marathon not a sprint the
goal if you're 18 or 21 or 25 isn't to
get rich by 30.
it's too i just think an 18 year old can
take a lot more risk well clearly you
should
the right experience for an 18 19 20
year old is like well you can bounce
back a lot easier that's why they say
that if you're just
not the dumb big mistake well not you
you cannot not going backwards no not
well i got into that 49
i mean i was into dead nonstop is what i
was into so but what i'm saying to you
is not the dumb mistake
you can't make a dumb mistake the dumb
mistake is you get caught something that
you know gets you a felony or something
that hurts you to go into a business or
your record things like that all the
other music you can lose all the money
in the world if you're younger not all
the money in the world but you can lose
some money because you can recover from
it of course
but but you're saying like getting
arrested
having a mark on your record like
selling selling
you know drugs just to make money i'm
not talking about play the long game
with that so i don't want anybody quote
me and say pat you said
anything to take the risk i'm not saying
that here's my last point i believe in
something called the kiss principle keep
it simple stupid
so we've talked sort of the theme of
this podcast so far is do your research
you know find out what's going on out
there so they're giving you a lot of
recommendations where you can kind of
put your money whether it's real estate
commodities
collectibles wine art diamonds like i
don't know anything about wine
other than if i'm gonna have a glass of
dinner yeah i'll take the cab cool
i'm not gonna become a wine investor i
don't know anything about art i'm not
gonna become an
art investor so i do know about
basketball i do know about the nba so
yeah i'd put 10 grand on a
zion williamson card because i
understand that marketplace
i understand hard assets like
real estate but i'm not trying to buy a
property so that's my big advocate of
reits
real estate investment trusts with
people out out there that aren't
familiar with
with that but diversify but i would say
regardless of your age 50 percent if not
more
of your core should be in the s p 500.
this guy is telling you to to you know
how you say hey
you know what he's doing is he's selling
because it's merrill lynch and all that
right okay
let's just say yes he is but but tom i
think he's observing
and selling but but i think if you read
it the guy says
real real real assets such as real
estate commodities and even collectibles
like wine art diamonds and car could
outport
outperform in the next decade those are
none of the products he sells
if you like he's not selling wine he's
not selling art he's not selling
diamonds he's not selling cars
that's not what b of a specializes in
correct he is selling
not selling away it's a bad term for the
financial industry but he's selling
to a different direction and imagine if
you're one of his advisors and you're
sitting there saying
why are you as a chief investment
strategist talking about mine what i
can't make money on how do you want me
to make commission so i can get your
money back to you you think he's facing
backlash no what i'm saying is
i like his honesty i like the fact that
he's act because most of the time when
he like i go to you know these events
with goldman sachs and the chief
economist will speak and all these guys
will speak
they'll typically give you whatever
recommendation
and you know you know what i'm talking
about but but i like the fact that
i don't know him i've never met him i
don't know his story i don't know his
background for all i know is he could be
you know someone who's against
capitalism but pull up michael hartnett
yeah but
all i can say is the fact that he's
selling this
the way he's saying cars diamonds art
and wine
yeah there's some integrity in it and
what he's saying that's awesome he's
saying cars he didn't i think cards but
cars i didn't say cars cars right which
i mean i don't know what kind of cars
he's referring to tom why don't you tell
us
tell us how much money is made in cars
collectible cars like literally
crazy crazy classic we're talking about
classic crazy money
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
put a line for the s p 500 and you put a
line for collectible ferraris the
ferraris are crushing it
sam n-e-t-t
i'm sorry tom keep going you were saying
no if you looked at ferraris
just as a from the 1950s 60s and 70s
just look at those
those vehicles and look at them say as
an s p 500 and the ferrari market letter
which is almost wikipedia the the stock
market for that
it is phenomenal the money you've made
on that and so you can go get smart
about it
you don't have to own it you can with a
consortium you can own them
it's just amazing by the way also this
this guy
how do we know that he he was honest
with what he said this is a business
insider story so
how much of all this did he expect to
see in print was that an offhand comment
that he made
talking about inflation and he makes an
offhand comment about cars and stuff and
it puts it in print
and then meanwhile business insiders
while she said in the story well that
part was off the record i wasn't
supposed to say that i was talking about
then
yeah the other things well it is what it
is you know what's really interesting
about the stock market
i saw something somebody asked me and
said look how do i how do i learn about
stock market i said look don't worry
about it
stock market's got a risky side and
stock market has a more conservative
side that has a lot less risk
and one of the best things i saw was um
you know 529s what's a 529 that's a
couple
of college college savings plan and so
who buys into college savings plans moms
and dads
right who might not know anything
about it other than maybe they have a
pension but the pension is managed by
somebody else
so they may not be retail investors with
any sort of knowledge of stock market
there's this great analysis that said
the closer your child gets to college
you can just click the box here and we
will reduce the risk in your 529 sort of
like a target date fund that they do
that's exactly right but
but again these people don't know what
that means but it was a beautiful
explanation that says hey the risk here
at kindergarten
is going to be here but we're going to
be reducing the risk the closer they get
to college
because although there is still risk in
this fund there's still risk of loss
the closer we get to college we want to
turn down the market risk that's our job
that's what you're trusting us to do
and then you read this thing and i'm
like when i first saw that i think it
was t.i.a cref did it
i said wow what a great explanation for
parents
that let you walk away saying okay this
is how the 529 is going to roll
and also it was a primer on being in the
stock market but not
everything is just throwing darts at the
wall i like that well i think with
anything with investing much like in
anything with life it comes down to risk
versus reward right
so something that i when i was like i
don't know how to invest i don't know
when i was in my early
mid 20s i learned about the 80 20 rule
the closer you are to age 20 the more
you can have 80 in stocks 20 in bonds
the closer you are to 80
more closer to 80 bonds 20 stocks
so depending on your age like pat like
said when he said uh when he was in
18 years old he took on a lot of debt
you have time to bounce back you can
take on more risk
not dumb risk not getting arrested not
out there selling drugs not getting in
stupid fights or anything like that
but the younger you are can take on more
risk the older you are if you're in your
80s
you shouldn't be in 100 equities you
should be in more likely 80 or 90
bonds and less stock so everything in
life comes at risk and reward and just
like the 529 plan
when someone's in kindergarten they've
got 18
you know eight no not 18. uh 12 plus
years to
for their money to grow i did some basic
math there versus if they're a
sophomore less time to make their money
grow
well i'll loop one more thing around
nfts because that's where this
part of this segment started is i don't
see any difference in what's happening
in
nft's first issues right now from ipos
there are ipos that come out and they're
a little bit rust it's a weaker company
but they have this amazing first day and
then they settle and then they all come
back
some of my last couple case studies were
companies that i showed hey well look
they had this huge huge pop came down
but then they stuck discipline
discipline
growth growth growth profit profit
profit and the price comes back up
i think that's you're seeing that with
nfts wow i love basketball
you know lebron james only making a
hundred versions of that one dunk his
first official nba dunk oh my goodness
pop well i think over time there's still
only 100 of those
so i think the value will come back but
it is kind of like
a little a lot of this was a little bit
of this ipo pop at the beginning
wouldn't you
have ipo i have a good idea for you uh
for our next segment we might cover it
today but if we don't
i'll tell it to you after the show i
mean think about it tom brady rookie
card sold for record-breaking 2.25
million dollars the autocraft 2000
playoff contender championship rookie
ticket
was a part of leland's spring classic
2021 collection
the opening bid was at 75 000 but 67
offers later
and the anonymous buyer walked away with
the item item for record 2.25
million dollars the card is one of the
only 100 ever made
and was previously purchased on ebay
over a decade ago when it remained in a
private collection before being so think
about it guy bought this on ebay
over a decade ago keeps it doesn't do
anything 10 years later puts an auction
sells it for 2.25 million dollars
the rare item received in eight and a
half grade and a
nine on the signature broke a record
prior record was uh 1.2 million
of also tom brady uh and then you also
have the super super mario brothers
game can you pull up the picture here
super mario brothers game
unopened so for 660 from 1986
type in super mario mario and then just
type um
uh unopened type in unopened
there you go uh open box yeah click on
that
let's see if it comes up 660. can you
type in 660 000.
660. yeah type in right there let's see
what comes up
go to news no no go to all all all
yeah uh there you go right there go to
the second one cnn
yeah uh
that's it look at that that sold for
660.
that right there sold for 660 thousand
dollars just because it's unopened it
got a grade of 9.6 so again
you can't duplicate that you either have
it or you don't have it
and somebody may say what a stupid thing
to own yeah
but it's unopened from 1986 which is how
many years ago
35 years ago someone sees value in that
so
you may have some things you're buying
right now that no one's paying attention
to sit on it for a little while
see what happens that's where i was
going with this there's a similar theme
here
you said sit on it i say buy and hold so
or as my crypto friends will say
buy and hodl you've seen that before
yeah so
uh good things take time as they say and
sometimes it's gonna take
a decade like the tom brady story or
sometimes it's gonna take three and a
half decades for your money to
matriculate but good things take time
and it goes back to my initial
philosophy that building wealth is a
marathon not a sprint well let me say
this though
zack shaw just gave five bucks yep and
he said just found out about
vt economics not vt okay vtn economic
channel yesterday adam you did a
fantastic job with the miami vacation
case study
and big shout out to the biz doc as well
thank you so much shout out to the
business economics and daniel de martino
and i just did an interview with
danielle that completely crushed it
and next friday i got a huge interview
coming out with none other than
the biz doc himself so yes we're uh
we're we're keeping it in the family
here but shout out to all our friends
out there watching valuetainment
looking forward to that i'm gonna sit
down with you next week buy and hold
we're gonna get to know the biz doctor
we're gonna have a beer during that
interview so
we should do that so uh we used to do a
beer in business
let's go to your best friend janet
yellen
oh somebody going with djt there you go
very wow
very big fan of when janet is said janet
yellen
yelling to push for global minimum
tax on corporations let me say that one
more time
yelling to push for global minimum tax
on corporations
cnbc however not just on corporations
she is pitching this to have a tax on
corporations around the world not u.s by
the way what he has here the story that
you have here kai
is not the story i was looking at is
there the story of she says global tax
or no
it's not going on top of page six okay
janet yellen will call for minimum tax
levy on corporations around the world in
an effort to keep companies from
relocating to find lower rates yellen
will tell
the chicago council on global affairs
conference that established a minimal
global corporate rate will help bring
stability and provide a more level
playing field for all countries
under the byte administration proposals
to raise a corporate tax rate as a way
to pay for two trillion dollar
infrastructure improvement plan
the corporate tax rate would climb to 28
from a 21
that increase would come just four years
after former president donald trump
slashed it from 35 to 21
which at the time was a heist in the
world at 35. wait back up and say that
again forget about trump
35 to 21 united states corporate tax
dollars years ago
in the world that's right forget about
trump what you feel about them 35
percent those companies here in america
are paying
more tax than anywhere on the planet
companies
companies also had him incentivized to
hide revenue offshore something the
trump tax cut
also addressed by adding reparation rep
rep
pronounce that word right there
repatriation
repatriation in other words big dollars
in savings accounts overseas get
bring it back to u.s banks yes the biden
plan would uh call for an
increase in the offshore tax rate to 21
from 10 and a half okay
all that stuff we've already talked
about let's let's emphasize one area
here
so janet yellen goes to the g20 saying
hey why don't we all have the same
corporate tax rate
rather than just u.s raising it why
don't we all agree on the same number
what do you think about that
well if you're and i have a list of the
countries with the lowest
corporate tax rate it makes no sense for
you to do because that's your
competitive advantage what are the
countries we're talking about
hungary nine percent montenegro nine
percent bosnian herzegovina uh
10 bulgaria ten percent this is
corporate tax right now you're talking
lowest corporate taxes
in the world uh moldova twelve percent
cyprus twelve and a half percent
everyone's familiar with that ireland
has very low corporate tax rate twelve
and a half pounds
albania 15 so you're talking about
basically somewhere about 10 and 15
for most of these countries this is
their competitive advantage
like why the hell are you going to
moldova or uh
montenegro unless they had to relocate
your corporate business
unless they actually have low corporate
tax rates so we kind of covered this
with byron last week
and it's stuff that it blew my mind i
didn't understand the double taxation
with
you know if your corporate tax and then
if you want to pull money out there's an
income tax and
yeah and all that but i think where
yellen is going with this
and a couple different points here is i
think what she's aiming to do i'm not
saying that these countries are going to
play ball because i think that it
mitigates their
um competitive advantage why would they
give that up but she's basically selling
this will prevent offshoring it was
essentially what that whole repatriation
incentivizing um thing that was true
that the trump tax cuts were addressing
so
i don't know if these countries are
going to play ball and i think this is
something she's what do you
think about it what do you think about
it what do you think about
getting the corporate tax rate for g you
know the top 20 whatever economies you
want to talk about
to be the same exact number what do you
think about that is that a good thing or
is that a bad thing
i think if you're america and you have
traditionally the highest tax rate 35
percent and trump got it down brought it
down to 21 and now it's at 28. or
biden's at least pitching 28. i know
they're in the round of negotiations
right now maybe they meet in the middle
of their 25.
i think it's freaking great for america
but i don't know who
i'm sorry who is america who is america
who is america you said it's great for
america who is america
american corporations you're talking
about taxpayers you're talking about no
no but you said it's great for america
who is america you said you said if
america is able to get this corporate
tax rate to
go and be the same it is great for
america
to keep our corporations why would we
want our corporations
so who wins though who wins in america
who wins in america if we keep all that
the same and there is no competition
for corporate tax rate which part of
america wins
the people the entrepreneur small
business owners
or the tax collectors in dc the u.s
government
the u.s treasury wait a minute wait a
minute you said all of the above wins
i think so tell me tell me how all of
the above wins well if the corporations
stay here
uh and they're paying lower taxes than
having to go elsewhere there's some
incentives at that
more jobs but obviously the big one is
taxes the irs you know i think that's
something that they'd be interested in
so
so then let me ask you a question who
keeps the government honest
if the government doesn't have any
competition who keeps the government
honest
corporations i guess how do you do that
you don't have the final say yeah the
corporations are nothing
they're nobodies how do you how do you
keep a government honest
if if the corporation has no other place
to go
like no other place to go i mean where
is the leverage for the customer
and the corporation to complain and say
we don't like the way we're being
treated
what's the government going to say go to
any of the g20 it's the same thing
yeah you don't like us you know go to
turkey
figure it out because it's same
everywhere
you lose officially
and you have no say you already if you
go to dmv and you file a complaint about
the envy on yelp
you know how many people read it nobody
yeah
go post the review on yelp and see how
many the dmv employees respond to you
go ahead try today yeah go to your local
dmv
go to the front desk clinton and
catherine or johnny
he's not gonna say hi how are you how
was your day well have a wonderful day
he's just gonna tell excuse me sit down
and go right on yelp
catherine told me to sit down and i
didn't like it and see how many people
are going to say
we're sorry you feel that way we totally
understand that's not the right approach
we are working to bring it up in our
next training routine to make sure that
never happens again
go ahead and see where tsa or yelp tsa
or dmv go file a complaint about tsa on
yelp
go ahead i'd love to see you do it let's
see what happens where's accountability
if all of a sudden right
yelling convinces all of these guys tom
let me just turn it over to you here
big countries have been doing this to
little countries for a thousand years
and the big countries are trying to take
the competitive advantage away from the
small countries
the reason apple's in ireland and a
million other examples you could have
is because there is an economic
advantage and there is a labor force
there
and it was better for them and better
for their stock price and better for
their overall return
and now you've got the empire strikes
back
where they're coming in and saying wait
a minute why don't we just make the
high tech tax rate even for everyone
she's not talking about the 15 tax rate
in ireland she's talking about the 35
percent rate
why don't we just make 35 percent every
now the small companies
small countries oh wow they're going to
collect 35 tax yeah but they're going to
have fewer
you know organizations coming to them to
do it so
big countries been doing it to small
countries forever i mean this goes back
to revolutionary times
where britain would harvest trees
from the us take them build furniture
and then
sell them back to the colonists that's
called mercantilism and people say wait
a minute
so you cut down the tree that was in
america you then turned it into a chair
and then sold it back to the american
that lived down the street from the tree
cut down yeah that's right
so big countries have been doing this
the small countries forever the fact
that yellen brings up her proposal
is only to benefit the dirt that she's
standing on when she makes that proposal
which represents
this is the u.s government the u.s
treasury that's it
president obama proposal announced last
week watch this that's my opinion
this is what she says by the way
president biden's proposal announced
last week call
for bold domestic action including the
race to raise the u.s minimum tax rate
and
renewed international engagement
recognizing that it is important to work
with other countries to end the
pressures of tax comp
competition and corporate let me read
the sentence
to work with other countries to end the
pressure of tax competition
hey ireland knock it off yeah let me
read this statement one more time
bold president biden's proposal
announced last week called for bold
domestic action including to raise
the u.s minimum tax rate and renewed
international engagement
recognizing that it is important to work
with other countries to end the
pressures of tax
competition
and corporate tax-based erosion
said miss yellen we are working with g20
nations to agree to a global
minimum corporate tax rate that can stop
the race to the bottom look
let me let me give you let me read those
last three lines stop the race to wear
the bottle which is benefits who the
government
no the race to the bottom benefits the
uh the smaller
the company that can go where it wants
but let me say this to you let me say
this to you
you ever hear when uh sanders gets up
there and sanders will say
an argument like this or sanders would
say obama would say it or hillary would
say any of these guys would say
how can we be the most powerful richest
country in the world and we don't offer
health care
every other country in europe does it
right you know what happens here
they can't use that argument because
when when a politician says that the
average voter says what
the average voter says huh if all these
other countries in europe and canada
offer health care why don't we you know
what i'll vote for it it is an american
right to have health insurance given to
everybody
because europe's doing it fair no
problem i get something i want something
you just told me i could get something
so now i want it but
flip it now on this side they can't say
we're raising a corporate tax to 28
because that's what all the european
countries do
see they don't have that statement today
to make
so they want to get it up so they can
say look it's what everybody does
it's normal it's what everybody does
that's right they don't have that
argument because the moment they say
they want to raise a corporate tax or
guess what republicans say
we are the highest we have the highest
corporate tax rate where
in the world and democrats are like and
then the voter the average voter who the
average voter
voter is not a dummy voter assistant
says we have the highest corporate tax
rate in the world why would america have
the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
let me go do a little bit of research
they come back and say
yeah i'm not with that i don't think we
should have the highest court even a
democrat
would say i don't want to have the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
but if they get this argument in
then guess what it's okay if we have the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
you want to eliminate competition with
government taxes are you kidding me
that's what saves
america where we have like the other day
i was talking to um
uh uh i can't wait for this interview i
lit i seriously cannot wait for this
interview to come out with
the guy who bought uh people's nft
medical bin right 69 million dollars
and uh he said i said so why do you live
in singapore
he says why do i live in singapore he
says no taxes on capital gains
my income taxes are around 10 or 20
percent no regulation i don't have to
report anything
nobody wants to know how much money i
have he says do you know why i don't
want to move to america i said why
look what the guy says he says i don't
want to move to america because i'm
worried the moment i go into america
for the rest of my life they can trace
me to pay taxes on things i did in the
past
because now they have my fingerprint i
don't want that singapore doesn't care
who i am and what i'm doing
singapore all they care about is for me
to pay 10 to 20 of income
zero capital gains low regulation
nothing
this is why myself and many others like
living
in singapore you think america likes
that hell no
do you think these politicians today in
the left like yellens and warren
and aoc's and biden those guys like that
absolutely not
but you know what a message like that
from singapore does
pisses these people off to say damn it i
was about to take you to 35
but you know what why don't we just
settle at 25 corporate tax rate
if we don't have that argument from the
other side they can take you to 35 you
can't say nothing because all they're
going to do is say
hey g20 we're going to take this for 35.
you guys also got to take it to 35.
and they have to do it it's a monopoly
so it's control
the word that i'm coming to mind because
you brought it up there is just
competition without competition you have
nothing do we have competition of course
right now this podcast does it have
competition yes we do
do you have competition with a live
setting yeah of course do i have
competition
does everybody here have a job have
competition yeah does tom have
competition
does the uber driver have competition
does lyft have competition
does a pizza joint have competition
doesn't it italy
you know a sub joint have competition do
states have competition
so should government why only put the
competition on
us small businesses and employees and
states and take the competition off the
government
how is that fair so we get to have the
pressure of going to sleep at night
worrying about our competitor
taking a market share from us but you
don't get to have that pressure no we
believe in equal opportunity
and you politicians also need to have
competition well
i think what it what uh you know as an
american you want to say like well no
you know
no america first and we no one should
compete with america no
it holds america accountable so we can't
get fat and lazy if you have no
competition you're the only person
you're the fat cat
you're only company doing x y or z and
you have no competition that's how
you'll become fat lazy sloppy
like your dmv example if someone goes on
to
yelp and says well uh mary down to the
dmv told me to sit down
and there's no response there's no
accountability how do you improve
so like you always say
outlast out improve and strategize
and if you don't have to do any of that
because you have no competition
that's how empires crumble absolutely
right and you know there's a little case
study on this it's really easy
eduardo savren who is the co-founder of
facebook
who moved to singapore and then
renounced his
u.s citizenship by the way he was living
in singapore since like 2007.
he renounces his citizenship 2009. and
people said
wait a minute you just did this to avoid
700 thousand dollars
700 um 700 million dollars
south of thailand and um in capital
gains tax
he said no no no my wife and i just love
singapore right and he now lives in
singapore
and so that's the whole point obviously
in southeast asia why do all that
up on why do the oil barons and the oil
pirates live
in belize same reason
people say oh these are tax havens these
no they're not this these are choices
these are valid choices
so you're saying that they're not tax
havens no no they're not if all taxes
are equal you wouldn't be living in
singapore
no way absolutely not if all taxes were
no you wouldn't but by the way
singapore is necessary go to images go
to images real quick where
by the way take the map outs everybody
kind of knows where it's at take the map
out go to the building with the pool
going out keep going out keep going up
keep going out
okay so go down a little bit pull it
down a little bit yeah you got thailand
you got vietnam you got cambodia
malaysia
south south right there to the east of
uh to the west of uh
uh uh indonesia indonesia you have
australia on this side but you kind of
see what
it's east asia the islands now go to the
images of singapore go to images of
singapore
go to images of singapore uh singapore
they go
and just click on images okay i got to
tell you kai sam's coming for your job
bro
there's a swimming pool that goes all
the way around that hotel it's a
beautiful hotel
are uh the what the shows that they have
you've been to singapore twice by the
way we can't hear your audio
so can you hear me now yeah go ahead
okay
the shows that they have a night with it
beautiful is it like vegas
is it somewhat like vegas vegas and
macau combined
yes yeah so so by the way a lot of
movies
are shot here just so you know a lot of
movies are shot in singapore it's a
beautiful place
and this is not a pitch for singapore
this is for a pitch that singapore is
very necessary for america
singapore is so imagine there is no
argument for us right now to talk about
what singapore does
the guy says capital gained zero why pay
taxes on cash he was confused he says i
don't understand why america taxes you
guys on capital gains
i don't get it why would you pay tax on
capital gains why are americans paying
tax on capital gains
right and biden goes back again this
week talking about a well tax
back at it again so this whole concept
about global corporate tax folks if
you're listening to this look
left right middle wherever you are if
you're listening to this
do a little bit of research on what
global corporate tax could do to you
especially if you're living in america
if you're living in
any other country outside of america
don't even think about voting for that
to be passed if anybody in your state
or country is pitching you on you know
the powerful people
of us are pitching us to have the same
corporate tax rate you may want to think
twice before agreeing
to want to vote for that go ahead
absolutely and here's something else
to go look at and everyone is listening
go get smart
go look at what the federal trade
commission was saying when
sprint and t-mobile were trying to merge
oh this will reduce competition
competition brings more features more
functionality
more differentiation and better pricing
for the consumer remember that pat
we if there's only two or three wireless
carriers they may all just freeze
pricing together like only two gas
stations on corner they face each other
and they never move
the price of gas down per gallon you
know what i mean so federal trade
commission is very big on this we
protect the consumer we want to make
sure there's competition in the
marketplace which brings lower pricing
new products differentiation those
people that are at the federal trade
commission
are specifically not allowed apparently
to be at the state department
because if they're at the state
department they'd be like what are you
knuckleheads saying the competition
among countries is good no no no go back
to the federal trade commission
you're not allowed in here turn that
guy's badge off don't let him get
through this door anymore
it's a hypocrisy that's inside of our
own government on one side we're arguing
that we need to level the playing field
for us
and on the other side we're at the
federal trade commission not letting
companies merge together because oh wait
a minute that would be monopolistic that
wouldn't
oh come on isn't it a hypocrisy yeah i
mean listen
one of the best things in the world is
the pressure of having competition the
pressure of having competition is what
makes
wives treat their husbands better
husbands treat their wives better
parents to be better parents men to be
better men
women to be better women teachers to be
better teachers customers to be better
customers employees to be better
employees
movies to be better movies sports teams
to be better sports teams
competition like the other yesterday
we're sitting at soho house
what did adrian put up on his phone
what did agent put on his phone what
were we watching oh you're watching the
game gonzaga
how many times do we look at the screen
five times yeah
in a span of 45 minutes you know why
because the game was why the hell am i
going to watch a 19 point lead by baylor
what am i going to watch and you know
the baylor the gonzaga guy
said i don't know if you saw this thing
going viral gonzaga guy said
we have the best offensive team in all
of college basketball
the baylor team said we lift weights
with baylor's football team
will go up your ass and that's exactly
what happened it was a shellacking on
what happened with the they lost pretty
pretty bad on whatever
the baylor bears but here's the point we
didn't watch the phone but five times no
i literally
looked 15 point lead i looked 11 minutes
17 point lead i looked
two minutes there's no competition
you will not pay attention to it one of
the best things for our health and our
sanity is competition
absolutely competition you would not be
in shape today if it wasn't for
competition
man i i i think this was a very powerful
segment that we just learned because you
know
it definitely resonates and i learned
something specifically about the
corporate tax but
it all comes down to competition we need
it buddy we just need it
it makes us get better that's that's all
i'm saying it makes us get better let me
give a quick shout out for a couple
people that gave some uh
uh uh contributed to the channel here uh
vt economics we give a shout out already
to him jonas
hi pat do you think china's involved in
military coup in myanmar
where democratically elected leaders are
detained and almost thousands civilians
killed what do you think i think about
that i mean obviously it's a
the point is i feel very bad for what's
going on over there
and unfortunately china is able to go
around doing what they're doing because
nobody's holding them accountable
and everybody's worried about losing
them because of commerce
and uh we're not right now from the top
treating them
in a way where they're scared of anybody
we just empowered them even more
from u.s government david berkovic gave
five dollars time to forget income taxes
consumption taxes raise more revenue
and don't disincentivize investment and
growth
it's a great idea will it happen in
america i don't know about that fifty
dollars from uh stephen carr
farkas pbd will you debate socialist
youtuber vanu on minimum wage check out
us
i will gladly debate anybody who's a
socialist but not a disrespectful one
and he's a disrespectful one i don't
have any time i have a very basic rule
you respect me i will talk to you you
cross the line and disrespect me i don't
have any tolerance for that and that's
not somewhere
where we will entertain i've had
communists on slavic gis
i've had richard walfound where we had
the greatest debate he was known as the
number one greatest socialist professor
in america by forbes
we had a wonderful conversation but
someone needs to learn how to respect if
you do that
by the way if i literally watch a video
and within the first minute you're
already disrespecting the person you
disagree with want to chose weakness too
you're not somebody that can do a debate
and we just move on next mr clean
bald guy gave five bucks what a nice guy
if you're needing the world to adapt
their tax rates because of your spending
habits maybe just maybe it's time to
adjust your spending habits
phenomenal quote that needs to be on
twitter mr clean guy tweeted seriously
needing the world to adapt their tax
rates can you
mr clean can you send that to me on
twitter and put hashtag pbd podcast i'm
going to retweet that of your tweet me
too
if you're needing the world to adapt
their tax rates maybe your spending
habits just
maybe it's time to adjust your spending
habits
martin mirage just gave three dollars
with a nice emoji
milan bognanovic five dollars saying
check out peter schiff's uh directly
addresses yelen's plan via
youtube and uh let's get back into it
folks if you got a question you can ask
it on twitter
pbdpodcast i actually look at all the
tweets so go on twitter
pbd podcast i and sam are following
those tweets next dana white to sell
his remaining shares uh
of uh ufc two decades after buying it
for a couple million dollars it's now
a seven seven billion who wrote this
article was one okay this is a euro
because it's pound
seven billion pounds which is what
roughly it's about a ten billion
elon musk joins the board of director
of ufc interesting they know what is
said to hand over
his remaining shares in ufc as parent
company endeavor prepares to take 100
percent
control over this company ufc dana white
was installed as the organization's
president back in 20 2001 after his
childhood friend
lorenzo fertitta and his brother frank
bought it for a couple million dollars
he cashed
in when he sold a chunk of his shares to
endeavor in 2016 in a cell
for around three and a half billion
dollars endeavor conglomerate ran by
hollywood super agent ahri emmanuel that
last name emmanuel they produce
some players has already built up a
controlling stake of 50.1 percent of ufc
and now it wants to scoop up the rest
and another boost for endeavor tech
billionaire llamas is now sitting
on their board what do you think about
the santa i mean this there's so much to
unpack in this story this is actually
the idea i had for you um because this
endeavor group is basically looking to
take the company public
this was an idea i had for you to do
maybe um a biz doc episode
um on whatever is going on here with
this endeavor group and ufc
i mean you go back 10 years ago
ufc wasn't even in the conversation as a
top sport
wasn't even the conversation i mean it's
not in the big three or the big four
whatever
basketball football baseball hockey you
know soccer
track and field boxing certainly it was
a comedy brand yeah
and now ufc is certainly bigger than
boxing these days
boxing is so below ufc these days that
the biggest fights in boxing
are 50 year olds mike tyson versus roy
jones jr
or wayans or wayans or
freaking jake paul versus nate robinson
like that's how
far boxing has sunk versus ufc so
and it all kind of falls on dana white
what he's been able to do
and it started with a 1.5 million dollar
investment or 1.5 million
pounds which is probably closer to 2
million
and now his 1.5 investment is worth what
seven billion what is that no no no not
his not dana white they know why cause
only ten percent
he has temperatures i've got eight
billion dollars and he sold some of his
shares and now he's gonna
sell the rest so he may have sold five
percent of it which for 175 million
dollars now he's gonna sell the other
five percent for probably 350 million
dollars so he's going to walk away he's
going to probably walk
with a half a billion dollars somewhere
what's his number what do you think i'm
going to say he's between 500 to
a billion dollars is where he's at 500
to 750. so what
the guy's a player what do you guys say
a thousand time x's money where's he at
it's not even about a thousand times
excess money if if dana white wanted to
run for office
he's got that kind of swagger to want to
do whatever the hell he wants to do he's
daniel
he's told he wouldn't do it because he
wants that freedom that he has
here's here's the thing with dana white
people don't realize uh dana white
let me just give this shout out to dana
what you can
replace great fighters you have to
realize the ufc's had anderson silva
chocolate del tito these guys were
legends even some of the old school guys
gsp connor where is he at connor the
diaz brothers
there are so many incredible fighters we
like oh my gosh i enjoy watching this i
want to see another fight of this guy
great armenian fighter great mexican
randall
i mean randleman was from a differently
the point i'm trying to make to you is
fighters have come and gone but there's
one guys that stuck around
and it's been dana white when you think
about ufc you think about one name
you think about dana white right they
got another they got a deep bench right
now of guys that could be the next dana
white
and their biggest challenge whoever buys
them endeavor
they have to make sure they keep their
dana white
look when boxing started take a hit
think about when boxing started to take
a hit i got a guy that wants to be
interviewed on vitamin who was uh
connected to the mob and he was one of
the biggest guys when it came down to
boxing you know we were talking about
this guy you know
his pr publishers reached out to us
where they manipulated fights hey you
losing second round losing third round
because it's so many ways to make money
in boxing vegas makes so much money
gamblers make that's a dirty side of it
as well right
you don't hear that with ufc but you
hear that live with boxing
you know when boxing start started kind
of uh drifting and people stopped
following it
when you no longer heard of a guy named
don king
okay people have to realize there is so
much
value in a don king there is where the
don
king was replaced by a fighter
mayweather
that's bad news when the don king
becomes a fighter
because a fighter is eventually going to
what stop fighting
the career of a promoter is longer than
the career of a what
a fighter for sure so especially peak
right so
if if whoever endeavor you know endeavor
comes in here takes you know dana
white's rest of the shares out because
they want to be 100
they better give this guy a fat salary
with a nice profit sharing against some
you know additional bonuses because the
guy's done a great job or
slowly but surely you better start
getting that bench set up of the next 10
12 guys that can potentially be the dana
white
somebody that's a true believer in it
and see what happens with it
bodybuilding mr olympia you know why
bodybuilding with strolling has been
dying out
why because nobody's replacing joe
weeder everybody's trying to be joe
weeder no one's replacing joe weeder
even the guy that we had on
valuetainment we interviewed him
who was one of the greatest promoters of
all time like literally one of the
greatest
promoters of all time oh man i cannot
believe i'm missing him um
uh uh you know you go back and you look
at
uh even uh wayne demilia phenomenal
interview i really enjoyed talking to
wayne the stories he told
uh all the things that he did promoters
are very valuable
whoever's buying this you better have a
deep bench
of someone with dana white tendencies
i agree exactly what you're saying and
what you're talking about is the forward
brand of a company
here's what's going on here so the two
brothers buy this let's think of that as
the venture capital stage for ufc
million and a half dollar seat funding
pretty damn big seed
and all they go then endeavor buys it in
16 for
three billion big chunk that they buy
there was probably a three year earn out
on that and the earn out is hey this has
to keep going this can't crash you have
to stay involved over three years
well that would be 2019 then we roll
into the coveted year of 2020.
now they want to buy the rest of it and
potentially take it public
so what they're trying to do here is
consolidate all the stock so that they
can take it public without complication
and that's what endeavor wants to do
endeavor is a talent agency i hope
they're listening to what pat just said
because you need a face of the brand to
go forward
this is a mechanical move to consolidate
the stock get ready for an ipo take it
forward that's great everybody can
invest in it wall street bets can talk
about it but if they don't have the face
of the brand
then guess what they've got apple
without steve jobs and
that's not going to work you need a face
to the brand
based on this you know you you need
larry ellison at oracle you needed steve
jobs here you needed gates and microsoft
there are faces that are i
that are they're out there by the way
that they're listening to the brand the
link to the brand
gates was a geek linked to microsoft you
know
jobs was a brilliant designer with
product instinct tom linked to the brand
would you give credit to gates for who
he replaced himself with
yes i would okay i would yes i would but
balmer
are you kidding me the guy
the amount of credit gates gives to him
don't get me wrong they bump heads and
it's not like a best friend relationship
that they had
but you know what balmer did to
microsoft yes you know what tim cook did
to apple i mean
you gotta so so i just hope they find
the right guy
replacing dana white that's a true
believer that's all i'm saying you think
they actually
they understand this like 100 percent 10
billion dollars without understanding
they get this they know exactly what i'm
talking about they're not you know
dummies no no not at all they know it
but sometimes
sometimes you when you make a choice
like this you can't choose someone you
like
that's right sometimes you choose
someone you like you have to choose the
right person that can do the job
and you typically don't like bill gates
doesn't love
bomber he's the right guy for it and
they have around
can you imagine how like you think about
dana white what do you think dana
white's like to have somebody that's
reporting to you to his board he's a
handful can you imagine dana white
coming in
well let me give you guys an update of
what's going on with our numbers no
imagine dana white in the boardroom i'm
so [ __ ] i can't believe he threw all
that [ __ ] through the window and this
[ __ ]
and we're going to go after oscar that's
who he is now the first thing is
hey dana's an hour wait again for the
board meeting are we having this board
meeting what are we doing here
you know where is this guy is he coming
here are we doing business today
say something you know because he's the
guy
that knows how to steer the pot and
that's exactly right the sea let award
the sexy sea let award of today's
podcast
oh my gosh competition competition baby
so sexy research and competition
competition
is so flipping sexy by the way
if you're listening you agree you
disagree
i love it either way comment below but
if you're enjoying the podcast
smash that thumbs up button and if you
think you're already a subscriber you
may not be because this is a complete
different channel
click that subscribe button and the
notification button so you will be uh
notified the next time we go live with
our podcast i have one point one last
point here
i want everybody to look at uh ufc and
go take a look at this
and look at who are their main big
sponsors like the official
soda the official beer look at all those
look at the money to give
to ufc do you think the nfl mlb
major league baseball nba do you think
they want those dollars they sure do
and so there's also a side of this that
they're competing for corporate dollars
for all the eyeballs of the young men
and women that love the brand
and dana white is a magnet that makes
that happen
there's that c word again competition
all right i feel like monster's the
biggest sponsor of ufc i just
proper it's probably monster but proper
12 would be
a billion dollar i mean mcgregor yeah i
mean i know you're helping i got to tell
you right there is something
do you think the other sports want those
dollars absolutely they do
who wants a dollar the other sports want
those dollars there is no face of base
basketball right they had to make it
lebron
the product is the face lebron's an
iphone 11. someday
lebron will be replaced by somebody else
he's a heck of a heck of an iphone but
the point is there's no face of the nba
the players are the face of the nba dina
white is the face the passion the future
the rudder of ufc can you imagine
president dana white
president dana white what do you have to
say let me ask you like for instance
tom brady has been in the face of the
nfl for 20 freaking years yeah
roger goodell is the
proverbial face of the nfl but people
don't like goodell
as he maybe and by the way not only the
owners do
the players do as well why are they
though wait wait wait okay let's do
something
by the way just so you know i'm not a
good dell i'm not here endorsing godel
god knows a few years ago you can watch
a video with what i had to say about
godel
better it's called saul this is not an
endorsement of godel
however however you ready and by the way
what i didn't like about godel is
one issue i have with godel the new one
has been the i
inconsistency he should have contacted
kaepernick asap and met with them and
the players association and said what's
bothering you let's come up with a plan
asap
he was afraid to do so it turned into
what it turned into they lost viewership
that's the only thing i don't like about
what he did however let's flip it
you ready so uh
how can a organization call the chiefs
can afford
to pay a mahomes a half
a billion dollar contract where the next
month
the guy made so much money he became a
co-owner of the kansas city royals
you know how they can afford to pay a
half a billion dollars because roger
goodell got so much
tv money that the chief said we better
pay this guy money because we just got
paid
so godel made mahomes a ton of money and
they just signed such a ridiculous
uh tv broadcasting yeah contract that
they
they the first time yeah for the first
time in 43 years they said well
we'll add an extra game so the nfl this
season add an extra week on to it nfl
fans
because it's no longer 16 games it's now
17 games
somebody said joe rogan somebody said
joe rogan will replace dana white
honesty i don't think joe wants that job
i think i don't think i think joe
believe it or not i think joe
is a he's got he's got a sweet side to
him
i think joe's got a sweet side to him i
really appreciate you saying that well
also an intellectual side to him he
wants to have
confidence yeah i think he's
conversation basically his rights and
understandings i don't think he's trying
to fight five five five five five joe is
not trying to be dana white no
joe joe is joe is one of those guys that
you watch and you say this guy's found
exactly the position to play
and he's maximizing that you ever see
somebody where you're like
i don't know why i watch you i think you
can kill it in something i just have no
clue what it is
but i don't understand why you're not
winning right now and all it is is this
different position they need to be in
joe's in a perfect position he needs to
be i don't know about joe being
dana white uh or wanting to be dana
white who knows maybe i'm wrong joe's
going to say i'm not i think i'm a
podcast with spotify
i'm replacing dana white's job and i'm
now running ufc i don't want to talk
about sports but you know
people find their find their home and
then become giants dennis
chrisley becomes a closer dennis
eckersley
out of everybody you know probably
ninety-two percent of the audience
doesn't know who dennis
lee is but they may know his mustache
forget about that
right forget about sports he was a
pitcher who found his home as a closer
and became one of the most dominant
closers of missouri in other words he
knew he was good at
he knew his position and he went there
and he was it and that's what you're
talking about guys we did it we have a
dennis eckersley and a cecil fielder
reference today
talk about 80s and 90s baseball pbd all
right again if you're enjoying the smash
thumbs up we're getting close to hitting
000 uh uh well ever since we changed the
time and came to florida we haven't hit
that number for a while but we're
looking forward to getting there all
right so
let's talk about uh trump going to
45th go to page five go to page five
page five page five trump
the 45th why trump is abandoning his
iconic brand for a number nbc news
donald trump spent a lifetime putting
his name on a st
stakes to skyscrapers to stimulus checks
but now the former president appears to
be replacing the gold-plated
surname with the number 45. last week
the 45th president launched his new
official website 45. office.com
literally the number 45 go to 45
office.com
let's see what it looks like a ura a url
unlike those of his pr
predecessors uh predecessors
predecessors predecessors who use their
names for their web addresses his
pack can be accessed to save
america45.com his white house old tweet
can be found
at whitehouse45 and when his attorney
bruce castor signed on to represent him
in a second impeachment case he said i
considered a privilege to present the
45th
president many politicians are known to
staffers and friends by nicknames or
initials
hillary clinton is hrc the former
president bush
are differentiated between 41 and 43 and
trump is
45 to many of his followers tom good
move or bad move
i think it's a great branding move and
also i think it's this is a a little
troll
of biden remember they created the
office of the president-elect and there
is no office of the president-elect
and they created podiums and everything
like that because they wanted him to
look official
they wanted him to say things before he
was inaugurated and all this stuff
so i think there's a little troll in
this but i think for branding
i think this is i you know i kind of
like it
he's creative you can't argue with the
guy's instincts and branding
adam i don't think there's any chance
that this was his idea
you're talking about someone who puts
his name on every single hotel he's ever
owned
golf course stakes on his plane
on his university and now and he's 74
years old he's like yeah let's just go
with
45 that's fine something's telling me
there's a branding expert that someone
came in and said look
maybe your brand is a little tarnished
i'm not so sure you want to just kind of
do that
and let's go with 45. so if it were up
to trump you know he would put his name
on that
doesn't get it i like the picture they
have here with the teletubbies you know
that's kind of a
teletubbies remember this
is that serious or no are those colors
serious on the right
that's actually on his website yeah
isn't that the teletubbies
i don't understand pat why do you think
he's going with this
45 office and not trump look let me put
it to you this way if there's a guy that
understands marketing better than 99.99
of the world as a guy named donald trump
period okay so he's not a
guy to say he has no clue what he's
doing this guy knows what he's doing
there's a reason behind it what that is
we're going to find out probably in the
next 24 to 36 months you're not going to
know for the next 24
to 36 months having said that okay
having said that let me kind of give you
the other side so that part i'm giving
the
credit to the strategist of trump the
marketing strategist that he is okay
if anybody thinks he's not a strategist
you are naive or you're a hater
period if you don't think he's a
strategist when it comes down to
marketing
that that picture is not the best
picture by the way
but uh uh but let me go back to this
some of these pictures that are coming
up man
on the website it's cracking me keep it
up actually keep it up because this is
good this is entertaining
but i will say this other part adam if i
can get your attention i will say this
otherwise yes sir
the other part on why he may have done
this intentionally
is to give his kids the freedom because
they're forever going to be trump
he wants to differentiate between trump
and 45 it's what he wants to do he wants
to be
known as 45 is what you're going to
remember him as
and he wants his kids to continue being
trump supporter because they're going to
be trumps a lot longer than he's going
to be a trump mm-hmm so he wants to give
his kids his grandkids baron who's now
what seven five he's about to pass up
minutes
george burasson you know the way he's
going that could be the case but my bet
is this is a marketing genius
the world is about to find out in the
next two years why he called it
45 office i may be wrong but that's what
i think but
i mean this isn't nothing new obviously
uh the the two bushes go by
41 and 43 that's sort of their moniker
the late 41. the late 41 and the the
current 43.
uh i do under i do i can appreciate the
the strategist mentality that that he's
likely doing
and he's probably thinking of legacy and
posterity and his kids and
and what will happen with that and maybe
differentiating
trump the businessman and versus trump
the president i can understand that
but there is something within his ego
that slaps trump on everything that's
like well
i don't know i kind of done pretty well
for myself
i don't think he does anything without a
reason nothing without a reason and you
know what's really interesting
is you know you always find out later i
think pat you're right you're going to
find out in two years
it was interesting do you remember on
bill maher uh ann coulter was on bill
maher and they were having
actually a pretty funny conversation
about the republican candidates and
there was like uh
16 total candidates uh and everybody was
remember this interview with everybody
was assuming
jeb bush was going to be challenged by
marco rubio and that was the race and
everybody else get out of the way
remember that
and then jeb bush looked like warmed
over dinner and
rubio never showed up she predicted
trump and she said
and bill maher says ann you have pretty
good instincts on this on the
conservative side
and you know who do you think is
has got the you know got the momentum
he's going to be here to run it she says
you're not going to like the answers of
all these candidates who do i think
has got the juice to be inaugurated to
be nominated
donald trump and everybody laughed yeah
and remember she arrived
bill maher and claire belmar remember
she turned her head like this and she's
like
she understands i kind of know what i'm
talking about but she knew she was
talking
about the base of the republican party
and she also knew that
who had a brand a message and momentum
versus who is being nominated by
just media because well if you're going
to be a president you have to be a
politician if you're a politician you
gotta be somebody who's
got the following jobs and she was right
but and everybody
flipped out but he drove that forward
and she was absolutely right and so
i think we'll find out in two years what
he's doing with this but i never second
guess what he's doing with the brand
because he's never dead he's not going
away he knows what he's doing
you may not like it you may not agree
with it you may not want it but
don't don't doubt it there's a purpose
do you think he has slept in
one day since he left office because
this is like some of the guy
who's up and at him cracking dawn moving
tweeting this that
do you think he's like it's had the most
hectic five years of my life i think so
i think so i'm sleeping until noon no i
think so don't wake me up melania
i think so i think so because
uh uh because melania probably made him
or not made him like hey listen babe
just take the you know date
take the week off i think so i actually
think he did because
i think this is a guy that uh
it's so funny to me when people
underestimate a guy that's been
competing
he's got 74 years of experience in
competition
competing against his siblings against
classmates against his dad's legacy
against
his mom suave against jersey against
manhattan against
local realtor gurus that weren't willing
to give him the permit against
politicians against other billionaires
against other news
media this guy's been competing for 74
years you know how much experience he's
got on his resume he should have his
resume saying donald trump
resume 74 years competition what do you
want to do
so obsessed with ratings because he
understands that ratings is competition
what are people watching
where the eyeball's going he's a
competition guy but he's not doing this
because he's done
he's up to something i don't know what
it is clearly that's what's gonna be
slept in one day because clearly two
days later and when you're saying he was
like
i do think he slept in one day i do
think this guy by the way you think he's
a four to six hour guy i don't think
he's a four to six hour guy
i think he's a six to eight hour guy
sleep yeah i think he's a six to eight
eight hour i don't think he's a four to
six at this phase i don't think he's 46
i think he's six to eight oh you're
compartmentalizing how long i think
during campaign he was a four-hour guy
but i think today he's a six to eight
and i think he's a daily napper where he
knows how to time his naps
as you get older you'll learn how to
refuel your body you understand your
body like your body's gonna tell you
listen kick it today i'm telling you
right now
yes you know you may want to you know
you understand your body some people
every day it's like that for them
they're like no i understand my body i
gotta sleep nine hours tonight
i'm not talking about that yeah i'm just
honest some people like mario last night
that's not mario last night driving by
the way i was just phenomenal
you know what i'm gonna give this video
to give mario a shout out because i
didn't send it on insta stories but i
think it's appropriate
should we do it or should we not do it
mario
you know it's by the way let's see
okay now this no listen i have been part
of a lot of prayers in my life
a lot what are you why are you laughing
have we been part of many
how many great people have you heard
pray i'm gonna air drop this too
tell me which one is it is it sam vt
uh vt studio imac which one you want to
send it to
which one okay i'm gonna send it over
there see if it comes up to you
is it coming or no take it but before
you pull it up don't pull it up i've
seen many
people in my life pray this was probably
one of the most special prayers i saw
yes because you couldn't hear the words
a prayer is such a strong prayer where a
person's face is telling you what
they're saying
it was i looked at you yesterday when he
was in the back seat you were crying you
got emotional it was it was a it was a
tough spot for me let's let's watch that
mario's method of a praying play it
this is mario's method of praying make
it
press the green button so we can kind of
see the full spectrum of this
go ahead
what a prayer look at that
look at that do you see it or no
dear baby jesus eight pounds six ounce
yeah praying
mario just so you know mario we love you
more than you would ever know you know
what mario did the other day on april
fools one of the best pranks ever yes
he sends an instagram story saying uh i
i have a
new consulting gig i have a new
consulting kick
and he says wish me luck wish me luck
you know
you know where to find me and you know
what ends up happening all the haters in
the world came out saying well
congratulations that pbd mother you know
and so he started realizing which one of
his followers are
valuetainers and which one of them
cannot wait but there were some people
that said
there's no way in the world i believe
this because you're mario if you know
mario
and his obsession with valuetainment and
his love for jokes about uh april
frickin fools
you could have read between the the the
lines on that one barry's a special guy
by the way today i believe my interview
with u.s armenians is coming out today
u.s armenians the folks from u.s
armenians came out uh
if you can you can go to youtube type in
us armenians
uh uh the interview is coming out today
i really had a good time with these guys
that's a lot of good questions a lot of
strong questions i mean he was expecting
me to uh
uh be a very direct the us armenians go
down
there uh go to their channel yeah the
interview i believe comes out today it's
a newer channel and they're going around
in their instagram blew up during the
whole time with what was going on
between turkey azerbaijan and armenia
but
check these guys out if you're armenian
go to their channel give them a
subscribe
uh give them some love the interview
should be coming out today it's about an
hour and we talk specifically on the
topic of armenians if that's not
something that interests you
then don't worry about it but if you are
armenian around the world go check these
guys out they're doing a great job
and they've been in the media space for
a while they came here from armenia to
do what they're doing phenomenal job
these guys are doing anyways okay
next topic i think it's important for us
to go to a serious topic which is
uh this may be the most serious topic
we'll talk about today adam was begging
me all morning to start with the story i
don't want to start off with the story
but we are talking about
vladimir putin is voted russia's sexiest
man alive daily mail russian president
vladimir putin the man who was famously
pictured topless
while riding on horseback and fishing
has been voted as country's sexiest
male a survey of 2000 russian men and
women found that the kremlin leaders
russia is the most
good-looking man in the country the
68-year-old bachelor was the only man to
reach double figures in the poll
by job board site super job when asked
who
was the most attractive man in the
country 18
of men and 17 percent of women voted
for putin he insisted in 2018 that he
was not embarrassed about the topless
snaps
and said he has saw no need to hide
behind the bushes
while on vacation so
adam i think this is since you really
wanted this story yeah do you think he
is the sexiest man in russia i mean i
think it's hard to not
see the sexiness in vladimir putin and
if you don't disagree
don't uh drink that cup of tea that he
just provided you
because there's likely poison in it so
um
he's been the sexiest man in russia for
the last 20 years sexiest man alive
sexiest man a lot of
sex there was a competitor but he's no
longer alive which means now
yeah his name is that's right
he's in second place only for one
afternoon we took care of it
are you really traveling home today you
may want to drive home today instead of
traveling from here
and taking a flight because you you know
you don't want to call this guy on a
podcast he's probably listening
go go for it just so you know russian
valuetainment channels got nearly a
quarter of a
quarter of a million subs now and our
content being translated in russian is
doing very good and some of your content
is russian so imagine if putin's watched
one of your case studies
tom when are you flying back to dallas
uh a week from tuesday okay
uh actually actually
it's pan am fight it's so over the top
ridiculous when i
keep the pictures up sam when i think of
sexy i'm not thinking of a 68 year old
balding pasty white some somewhat flabby
guy
that ain't screaming sexy to me so we
talk about competition
yeah this guy's got no freaking
competition by the way are you saying if
you guys got into a fight you'd beat him
up at 68.
do you think you could beat him up i'm
being serious
yeah i'm looking to go viral so yeah i'm
challenging vladimir putin to a
one-on-one
horseback fight duel that angle you have
right now is not necessary go look okay
that's better okay
um no we we do it better in the united
states we have better examples i mean
this is
that's like basic this is the equivalent
of basically america being like
breaking news guys bernie sanders
sexiest man in america
that's the equivalent of what's going on
go to the site because if he wants you
to go to that site
i don't know what he wants you to look
at um
let me show you how we do it in america
we do it a little bit different
okay got it this is how we do it in
america ladies and gentlemen
this is how we do that's sexiest for you
sarah palin well i'm saying to some
americans
okay go to the fake original what is
that the second one that's hilarious
we're gonna go to
that one that says fake and original
right there buddy it's on the page you
got nine options one of them says fake
original go down
there you go oh i see okay they're just
playing it's not even her
yeah got it oh it's not even for
somebody else got it it's fake
fake news you can go back to the other
picture with uh putin i will tell you
this it's like when putin runs for
election he gets 90
of the votes i think you guys are
missing the point i think you guys are
missing a point
listen here's here's the point and
hopefully this will make sense to you
do you remember in the 90s what calvin
klein models look like
80 pounds they were cocaine heroined out
well especially the females
i mean it was just like what like heroin
sheik
moss there was a joke the joke was the
diet coke and coke diet
yeah yeah am i supposed to be like
saying oh my gosh she's so hot she's so
attracted she's dropped
no and then you had
a different taste and flavor that showed
up back in the days with marilyn monroe
or sophia lauren we were just talking
about them earlier right it was a
different
uh where you said oh wow look at that
they call them ambitions
are you basically saying you're a fan of
sir mix a lot no that's not what i'm
saying
baby that that uh let him finish his
honor
it's uh uh poetry there you know by what
they came up with
i like big bucks but i'm gonna tell you
this but here here's what i'm gonna tell
you
to russia they value toughness
strength confidence swagger
you you fear it's a different level of
attractiveness like in usa too it's
michael b jordan
it's dwayne johnson it's robert downey
jr george clooney matthew mcconaughey as
those guys
right well in russia they want guys like
this they want a guy to be tough
so in russia it may be that he is the
sexiest man alive to a russian
he may be the sexiest man if ryan
gosling
and him went on a catwalk
the room wouldn't be looking at ryan
gosling they would say
look at this guy you know what he said
right there you know what he's saying
right there you want a piece of me take
a look at that
yeah he's looking down somebody said hey
get off the horse really yeah
yeah putin is probably what people i
like putin is what they're saying
it's a little bit of russian that i know
so there you have it so adam are you
satisfied we covered a story so do you
actually would you vote for if you lived
in russia would you be voting for him or
not i don't think i'd be vote i don't
think i've ever voted for sexiest man or
woman alive but
uh if they did they have your vote i
think he is the toughest
leader alive today that's what i would
do in my house i won
sexiest man at my house 18 years running
oh you won in your household yes i did
18 years tom yeah that's pretty
impressive i forget about the pool boys
because you want to know why i'm
undefeated i want to know why tom cause
you have no
competition bro if you were had some
confidence so you're saying he's got an
element of yelling in his house just
saying yeah you need something
like yelling what's going on here okay
can we talk about the mlb move can we
talk about i'm gonna go do push-ups
let's let's talk about let's talk about
mlb moving the all-star game and let's
see if fires if we're gonna get some
fireworks here i don't know i think
fireworks this is not a sports story
this is a political this is a political
story okay so let's get into it mlb move
in 2021 all-star game from atlanta in
response to georgia voting law usa today
story
major league baseball will move its
all-star game out of atlanta after the
state georgia passed
voting bills that will
disproportionately this is the story of
usa today
affect citizens of color and action that
commissioner rob manfred on friday said
is the best way to demonstrate our
values as a sport mlb's removal of one
of its
jewel events which this year will
include the draft for the first time
comes after a year
in which the covet 19 pandemic and the
killing of george floyd by minneapolis
police officer called caused the sports
industry to reconsider its influence
with its society on march 26 governor
georgia governor brian kemp signed
legislation
passed by both state house a republican
let over
overhaul of state elections rolling back
voting by mail
and other absentee ballot efforts and
even banning the distribution of food
and water to
those standing in line to vote which by
the way we're going to verify that
mlb did not specify to which city it
wrote relocate the alistar all-star game
which due to its fixed date
and loan spot on the sporting calendar
is its biggest corporate event of the
year tom give us your thoughts on this
i i think it's first of all i think it's
good
when you know we're all taking a stand
together as citizens
but you know this is this is very
political i mean there's a lot of small
businesses in georgia that may not
that are not on the left they're on the
right they're just here they're
independent and
now they're going to be hurt they were
expecting hotel rooms they were
expecting restaurants they were
expecting a lot of things who are coming
back for the summer and there's a lot of
small businessmen and people
in that local economy you're going to
get hurt and by the way where do you
draw the line of being upset
where do you draw the line on being
upset you know that
you know what happened with george floyd
and the things that we have to do and
the the improvements and the
all the additional ground that we have
to take
so that everybody's got a chance and all
these things are
you know less prevalent every new
generation that comes along
is very very important that importance
is not diminished
but you're there's a lot of business
people and there's a lot of things there
the georgia government does something
and but and
both houses and then everybody's upset
and now all these business folks get
hurt so i you know i'm
i'm bummed out about it but there's
things underneath that
are very very important but i'm really
bummed out that
that the political wave comes over like
this and it's going to hurt other people
in the process
yeah i'm going to give a couple
different perspectives here it's so
funny because florida always gets a bad
name
for just everything and whether it's
politics whether it's
social whether it's everything makes
poor sports fans
and george's this past year is just
basically like hold my beard we got this
whether it was the elections for the
senate run and now this uh just a couple
different sides of the coin here so
you talked about the businesses being
hurt they said that a hundred million
dollars is going to be lost to the state
of georgia
100 million dollars by that so that's
the tax to georgia
that's not the underlying revenue to
those little companies
say it again that's the tax to georgia
that's not the
that's not the underlying revenue for
everybody that sells hats
t-shirts you're saying it's bigger than
100 million
yeah the revenue to all the little
business people and stuff
is much bigger according to cnbc they
lost 100 million dollars that's but
did did you just catch what happened
right there like so when thomas saying
100 million is just to the state there's
going to be a lot more money that's
coming in through the small business
billions
that's billions it could be potentially
a couple billion yeah come with you on
that
uh by the way it did get moved to denver
i don't know if you heard that yet which
totally makes sense
okay so obviously big blue state
so a couple different things here so if
you have brian kemp the governor of
georgia who got completely
lampooned by trump all throughout the
senate race
he came out and he said this is
disgusting this is cancelled culture of
the highest hypocrisy this is ridiculous
like
let's keep politics that's what's
confusing about it what you just said
but continue
okay yeah um so keep sports out of
politics keep politics out of sports
and then you have uh companies like coke
delta uber lyft
paypal under armour estee lauder they
all pulled out of it and then obviously
when they start pulling out everyone
else starts pulling out of that but
something that
has actually manifested certainly during
the pandemic
and certainly during uh the blm movement
social justice movement
is that you know the whole lebron shut
up and dribble right
so sports stars and even ceos are no
longer just sticking to business they
are now putting their hands into social
issues
and into politics and they're kind of
getting deeper involved
other than just sticking to business so
sports players aren't just shutting up
in dribble
business people aren't just following
following the business of focusing on
the money
they are taking a stand on social issues
and
whether you agree or disagree those are
sort of just two sides of the coin
um but sports business politics
whether you like it or not they're sort
of all intertwined
and this is sort of the culmination of
all that where
the mlb all-star game where you're just
like look it's an all-star game why are
we making this political yeah
it's now all a big [ __ ] show so here's
the here's the thing
officially we only have one sport left
that has now been politicized
only one so now i thought baseball was
going to stay
you know neutral and independent now
there's only one sport out of the top
four sports that's no longer politicized
hockey hockey is the only one
nfl hardcore politicized well with all
the nba
hardcore nba is like far far far
politicians they even have last names in
their jerseys
it's just too much now now you got mlb
and then lebron comes out and gives a
shout out and says hey great job mlb for
standing up so did obama so did a bunch
of other people
and they're claiming that what a biden
did in the interview with espn is
gaslighting because he went up there and
he says
i want to applaud the mlb you know for
for standing up for themselves and
let's face i mean you're trying to say
this is like jim crow this is you you
can't even give people water
i mean what do you mean we can't even
give people water biting is saying that
you can't even give people water
he said he can't even give people a
bottle of water is what he's saying so
you can't go out there now
i went and said okay that's pathetic if
you can't even give the people that are
voting
bottle water only poll workers now let
me tell you i got the article
and i got it from washington post and
heritage let me tell you the difference
washington post hardcore left jeff bezos
heritage action conservative hardcore
right okay
i'm going to give you both of them and
you make the decision for yourself
okay so let's go through washington post
the article if you want to pull it up so
people can see the title of it on
washington post
expand access a historic restriction
question mark what the georgia voting
law
really does so go up a little bit to the
main one
so how does the law limit go all the way
up where it says how does the law there
you go how does the law limit voting
it shrinks the window of voters to
request mail ballots rather than allow
voters to request mail balance six
months from election day the new law
says voters can start requesting ballot
78 days out okay so you lost 90 days of
asking for it counties can begin sending
ballots to voters
just 29 days before election rather than
previous
49 days it also sets an earlier cutoff
date for ballot
application request critics say any mail
delays with these shorter periods
could lead to voter not getting ballots
on time or not being being able to
return there in time but proponents of
the law
say voters simply don't need the 180
days they used to have to request
ballots and that moving up the cutoff
date makes it less likely voters will
receive ballots too late
to get them back in time to be counted
okay you can make a decision say you
like it you don't like it but that's one
of them
next counties in the state can send mail
ballot applications only to voters who
request them as opposed to simply
sending every registered voter a ballot
application and cannot fill in
information ahead of time
next by the way if you guys got comments
comments as i'm going through no voter
id requirements
voters may who cast mail ballots will
have to provide one of several
forms of identification this provision
which replaces the signature match
previously used to conform
confirm voter identities is one of the
most controversial because critics say
it's likely to disproportionately affect
black voters like what do you say about
that town the fact that you have to show
an id
and they're saying it's it's it's not
fair to show id's
what are you saying what do you mean
there are several forms of them it's not
just a driver's license because maybe
your drivers are suspended maybe you
don't have it
there you know there's several forms of
identity yeah i can't comment on
anybody who's analyzed it and say it's
disproportionately going to affect
one group of voters or not but there was
several forms of identification there
was a list
yeah so again but that's one big
argument we'll come back
one of several forms have been and
anything you have identification to to
go in and get
health care at an emergency room coke
who supports this decision with mlb
if you want to go to the annual co
convention you have to show your id when
you go in
the level of hypocrisy on what people
are saying here's basic idea for me to
know who you are it's not a big deal for
you to show your id
voters don't have to provide a copy of
identification but could example provide
a driver's license number social
security other acceptable
identification this is not a big deal
next a limit on the number of ballot
drop boxes during early voting it
essentially limits the number of drop
boxes in each county
to one per early voting site or one for
every 100 000 voters in the county
whichever number is smaller and the drop
boxes can't be conveniently spread over
the county for example in places where
there aren't in-person early voting
locations
they all have to be located either in
the county election office or at an
early voting precinct
location they have to be indoors which
critics say make them less accessible
and could
lead to crowds where voters are already
congregated
tom you're shaking your head that's
ridiculous because what they're saying
here is
let's put the boxes in a place where we
can watch them and make sure
everything's cool
and by the way if this goes both ways
because
either party will be screaming about
this based on who won yesterday
you know that of course this this is
trying to put the boxes in a place
where we know where it is and the votes
can be counted properly
and we want to put it in a place where
it's less likely
you might we get a third yeah it's just
i think that's i think that's
really stretching and reaching they're
trying to say
here's the drop-off locations we're
going to put them here here and here
you know we're talking that's their
argument though that's washington post
argument let's go to the next one
shortened early voting and runoff
election instead of a minimum of three
weeks of early voting and runoffs early
voting and runoffs will be held in a
single monday through friday period
the next one state lawmakers get much
more power over county and local
elections and republicans have decisive
majorities in both states senate
and state house today today the law
states that the general assembly will
select the chair of the state elections
board rather than the board being
chaired by the georgia secretary of
state
an elected position the chair is
supposed to be nonpartisan the state
election board can investigate county
election board
and has the power to suspend county
election superintendents
though the law limits the state board to
suspending four at a time
you might remember georgia secretary of
state brad who became the target of his
own parties ire
after president donald trump asked him
to find votes in the wake of 2020
election this provision seems like a
direct reaction to that ensuring
partisan state lawmakers can control the
elections process more directly let's
not forget kemp
did not do what trump asked him to do
and trump couldn't stand what kemp did
to him
so just five months ago kemp was a good
guy now kemp's a bad guy
even though he didn't defend trump trump
was asking him to
take care of him and didn't happen next
a ban on handling handing out food and
water within 150 feet
here comes the truth or within 25 feet
of any voter republicans say this is
aimed at stopping
outside groups from influencing voters
democrats say it's supposed to make it
harder for people to wait on long lines
particularly
on hot or cold days election officials
are permitting to set up water stations
but they're not required to do so we're
going to go into more details
on the one from heritage action because
they actually explain
what that really means that that means
i've
stood in line to vote for over an hour
and it was here in dallas and it was a
warm day
and what this is you are not supposed to
be approached by
any person while you're waiting and
nonpartisan can give you water
partisan cannot give you that's right so
if the league of women voters sets up a
water station there so i can get water
on the hot day
i can get water no one's depriving them
but what they're saying is
you know when you get out of your car
and they say excuse me are you voting
for this position or that position
but as soon as you cross like where the
cones are they can't talk to you anymore
you're now in a polling place and no
one's supposed to be within so many feet
of you
that's what this is about this isn't
about depriving people water we got four
minutes i want to go through both of
them a few ways to ex it expands
voting a minimum number of drop boxes is
guaranteed kemp has been arguing
publicly
that in rural counties that didn't have
drop boxes in previous elections
this is an improvement drop boxes
weren't allowed in georgia at all
before 2020 and not all counties had
them even during the pandemic world
while the number dropbox is so limited
it might not make a huge difference for
voters kemp is correct that the law for
the first time
codifies requirements for a minimum
number of drop boxes in each county
phenomenal that's very good keep going
up keep going up keep going up yeah now
they're required there must be drop-offs
an additional day of early voting in the
rural counties the new bill requires at
least two saturdays of early voting for
each primary and
general election previous georgia law
required only one it allows
counties to choose when their early
voting locations are open for a minimum
of eight hours between
7 am to 7 pm reasonable more resources
for precincts so lines don't get too
long the law basically requires the
state to monitor polling locations to
see if any
have lines longer than an hour or still
have voters waiting in line
for more than now after polls were
supposed to close in those cases the
state is required to either form
new precinct locations to ease the
strain or beef up the existing polling
locations
capacities to handle a large number of
voters this applies specifically to
populist precincts
mostly in urban areas sounds like more
opportunities i agree as well
here's what didn't make it into the bill
a block on sunday voting earlier
proposals called for a ban on sunday
voting this proposal was seen as
directly targeting black voters who
often
vote as part of church run so the polls
effort that takes place
on sunday this is a good thing they can
still vote on sunday they can all take a
walk down together there's a good thing
yes a ban
on no excuse absentee ballot time just
turn off your ringtone just turn it off
yeah
a ban on no excuse absentee voting
georgia republicans actually passed the
bill in the state senate a few weeks ago
that would
have been no excuse absentee voting
one of the most criticized but on not uh
uniformly agreed upon jp personal
okay so so that's washington post go to
go to american heritage go to heritage
action for america this one's short it's
just two pages
okay myth versus fact the georgia
election law okay myth number one the
georgia election law discourages voting
suppressors votes
fact the bill actually preserves or
expands ballot access in several
important ways it requires that large
precincts
with lines more than an hour take long
take uh hour long take steps like adding
voting machines an election personal for
the next election to reduce wait times
it does not change the number of total
early voting days actually increases the
mandatory days
of early weekend voting compared to 20
20 134 159 counties will offer more
early voting hours than future elections
under the new law it codifies election
okay we read that all right
voters can continue to vote absentee
with no excuse unlike states like
delaware which who is from delaware by
the way
isn't a guy named joe from delaware i
think he's from joe biden's from
delaware
voters can continue to vote absentee
with no excuse
unlike delaware which is where joe
biden's from
new york connecticut which required an
excuse to vote
absentee myth number two the georgia law
eliminates voting
on sunday to surpass african-american
votes georgia law was silent on sunday
early voting days prior to sp 202
and in 2020 only 16 out of 159 counties
offered early voting on sundays the new
law
expires explicitly provides the option
of holding early voting on two sundays
for all locations it actually increases
the mandatory days of early
weekend voting across the state that's
myth number two number three
there's only six of these so hang tight
the georgia election law suppresses
the vote with a onerous onerous voter id
requirement the law requires a driver's
license or
a free state id number which 97
registered voters already have
anyone without valid id can easily
obtain one for free the voter id
requirement replaces the state's
controversial signature match program
that led to disqualification of
thousands of votes in 2020 the law's
voter id
requirement for absentee ballot is
overwhelmingly popular in georgia across
the board according to
agc atlanta journal constitution the
newspaper in downtown atlanta
in january 74 percent of georgia voters
support it including 63 percent of black
voters and 89 percent of those making
under 25 000
a year interesting so that data is now
being written by washington post
but now we know you can click on the
link agc to go to it not yourself sam
the audience if they want to do it not
us myth number four the bill
the bill eliminates drop boxes for
absentee voting fact the drop boxes used
in the last election did not exist a
year ago they were
first utilized in 2020 as a pandemic
precaution the bill makes them as an
official part of georgia elections and
they will be available 159 counties
and under supervision to protect against
tampering number five
the bill lets republicans throw out any
county votes they don't agree with
the by fact the bipartisan state
election board can do performance
reviews are local election supervisors
who failed their areas voters
with things like long lines and off of
absolute value the board will not
overturn election results the law simply
provides a process to review and
ensure officials are technically
competent and complying with the state
laws
the process requires a high burden of
proof someone's okay okay god and then
last but not least myth number six the
bill bans drinking water for voters
while waiting in line fact like the
countless other states that have very
specific laws against elih
electioneering near polling places
georgia has
codified rules preventing political
groups from handing out food or water to
voters
in line as an incentive to vote but
specifically allows poll
workers to make water available to
anyone who wants it the law
will also directly cut down wait time
meaning refreshments for people waiting
in line
will be necessary this law didn't move
the all-stars
right yeah i was going to say this did
not move the all-star game
joe biden gaslighted and moved the
all-star game
i mean that's what people are saying
that's the spectator and everybody and
by the way coke
and everybody else sees the world
reacting they want to be on the right
side of history so they say okay we're
out
because they don't want to explain that
something is misunderstood they're like
no i'm not going to get in the middle of
this if this is getting too hot then we
have to move and we have to be on the
right side of history look
even though this is really sad the
audience has the choice
to pick and choose which article they
want to read i give you both of them and
put the link below for people to go see
it if you can comment below as well can
you do that oh you want to put in the
description
put in the chat box right now so people
can go to it if they want to go to it
but here's the point yep what happened
over there was so politicized
right that atlanta you know braves took
a hit
small business owners took a hit major
hit fans
took a hit huge hit massive hit why
rob manfred already made a dumb decision
a couple years ago when the astros did
what they did and he didn't suspend
anybody
and he said if anybody hits them we're
going to suspend you none of the astros
players got any kind of punishment the
gm got fired or whatever happened to him
nothing happened there two years later a
year and a half later he was saved by
kovat everybody forget about what
happened to astros
okay right except from some fans that
are going on with trash you know at the
games
still beating us a year and a half later
he does it again
and he is going to bring back up the bad
decision he made with the astros but he
is using this as a way to win the
journalists and the commentators that
were trashing him just a year and a half
ago for the decision he made with the
astros
it's his way of winning some cool points
and uh he may win it
100 percent but you took a hit with the
league maybe wrong that's my thoughts
adam final thoughts yeah no
this is the beauty of listening to the
pbd podcast is that we're going to give
you both perspectives and you can do
your
own research to figure out what makes
the most sense and what the truth is but
we're going to kind of give you both
sides of the spectrum
and as they always say if you have two
different perspectives the truth
sometimes is
uh in the middle uh and so go do your
own research i don't know if we have
enough time to
this kind of fits in with the sports and
the politics to cover the barkley stuff
but
i wish i did we'll do it on thursday and
thursday is who who's thursday thursday
we have uh
oh ricky's here thursday phenomenal you
you're gonna be able to i gotta go work
out i gotta go work out right now i
gotta go pump some weight i think this
is gonna come straight
you enjoyed today's podcast with tom
smash that subscribe button tom thank
you for coming out
uh adam had a good time with you and sam
shout out to you kai
ricky i know you're listening the chair
is warm you are going to
kill it here and if you haven't seen
ricky tune in on thursday to see
ricky we will have a metal detector
before you walk in the building do not
come straight you're so funny you
[Applause]
everyone
you